Does the Dutch test include that as well as adrenal hormones?
So the Dutch test only includes cortisol levels and DHEA.
And it gives you a cortisol rhythm. So your cortisol is released in a rhythm
as well as many of your hormones are.
And you have to make sure you do it on a day that is you're not under a lot of stress or
kind of invalidates it.
But it's going to give you the cortisol rhythm through the day.
You're taking a test through, you know, four different tests through the day to get the cortisol rhythm.
That could be a beneficial test, but that's really measuring just the needles.
So that's going to measure what that will tell you is if your rhythm is still good,
you still have a nice rhythm, but everything is suppressed.
That means you have adrenal fatigue.
If you're rid of, if everything is high, then you have an excess cortisol output
and just excess chronic stress.
Or if it's just flatline, it means you have complete adrenal, adrenal, just
complete adrenal fatigue or what's it called, just complete adrenal waste that we
really need to get into support of your adrenal glands.
So there's benefit in doing a cortisol rhythm test.
I think there's benefits to that.